-It is time to play
a game of deception
called "True Confessions."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
My first opponent tonight
stars in the #1 movie right now,
"Spiral: From the Book of Saw."
Please welcome Chris Rock!
Whoa.
-Playa.
-That was smooth.
-That was very smooth.
-You just slid in right there.
That was fantastic.
Chris and I will be facing off
against a Grammy-winning artist
who produced the soundtrack
for "Spiral."
Give it up for 21 Savage!
-Savage.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on, now. See?
That was good.
That was cool, too.
You just kind of
came up right there.
Welcome. Now, look,
here's how this works.
In front of each of us
are two envelopes
containing confessions.
One is true,
the other is a lie, alright?
-Mm!
-Once you read your confession,
the other two players
get to interrogate you.
Then they have to come
to a unanimous decision,
is it the truth, or is it a lie?
Chris, you'll go first.
-I'm going to go first?
-Which -- What do you think?
-I have 1, right?
-Yeah, okay. I say --
Yeah, why not? He's holding 1.
-Got to hear it.
I got to hear it.
-Alright, let's hear it. #1.
-Let's hear it.
-Yeah, let's go. #1.
-Is it one of them
Usher "Confessions?"
[ Laughter ]
Is it a Usher "Confession,"
or is it
a Justin Timberlake "Truth"?
[ Laughter ]
So let's see.
Truth?
-That's true. That's true.
-Wait, you don't even -- You
don't even ask him questions?
You just think it's true?
-I know it's true.
-Let's -- I know Chris --
-Do I reek of weed right now?
-Chris doesn't, I don't think --
Chris doesn't smoke weed.
-Oh, I smoke.
-See, I told you.
-Not around me, though.
-I told you.
-Well --
-See, that ain't the real Chris
when he probably around you.
-Really?
-He the real Chris --
-See, I have
different drug habits
around different
races of people.
[ Laughter ]
-So you --
But you --
-When I'm with white people,
it's just all Jaegermeister.
[ Laughter ]
-That is my jam. So, you and --
Why are you on the top
of the Empire State Building?
-Why I'm on the top
of the Empire State Building --
Because we were --
Well, we were doing --
There were -- There was a moment
where we were going to do,
"You Got Mail" Part 2, right?
-What in the -- What?
Are you listening to this?
-"Sleepless in Seattle"
Part 2, Right?
-Uh-huh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, right.
Yeah, and you're going to do it
with Woody Harrelson.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-I don't know.
I think Woody Harrelson,
yes, he likes weed.
Was it one of his joints?
-It was one of his joints.
-Yeah, he does
like a serious thing.
I don't think --
You're joking about the movie,
but why you're on the top
of the Empire building
with Woody Harrelson?
I don't think
this is true at all.
You think it's true?
-Yeah, I think it's true, man.
I think it's true.
-It's very windy
and breezy up there.
-It's very windy and breezy.
-You got to cover --
If you're going to light a joint
on the top
of the Empire State Building,
you need, like -- You need
big hands to cover that.
-Jimmy, when you
want to get high --
[ Laughter ]
-Alright, final --
What do you think?
You think he did do it?
-Yeah.
-Right, I got to go with 21.
Alright. I'll say you did do it.
[ Drum roll ]
-I didn't do it.
I didn't do it.
But --
♪♪
-Why you go with me for?
-Well, because you're my guest!
I don't know!
-I have smoked a joint
with Woody Harrelson,
Snoop Dogg, Willie Nelson,
and Kelly Ripa.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright, this is my turn.
Which envelope
should I open, 1 or 2?
-2.
-Right, here we go.
-He opened 1, right?
-Yeah, I opened 1.
Savage.
[ Laughter ]
-So you were on "Sa--"
Okay, were you on this show
or were you on
"Saturday Night Live"?
-I ended "Saturday Night Live."
I was doing "Taxi."
-"Taxi."
-She was on the --
-With Queen Lati--
I don't even know if "Taxi"
gets you Gisele level --
-First of all -- First of all...
-I saw "Taxi."
-...she's in "Taxi."
-Oh, she's in "Taxi"?
-She's the villain.
-Oh.
So y'all had
some rehearsal time.
-Wasn't a long thing.
-Gisele.
-Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, he did.
He did. He did. He did.
-Does Jimmy Fallon
have that much pimp in him?
[ Laughter ]
-She's really into horses.
We ended up going
to, like, a dude ranch.
-Really?
-He did it, bro.
He did it.
-I'd never ridden a horse
or got near a horse.
-He slipped up.
You ain't hear him?
He say,
"It wasn't a long thing."
-I'm going to say yes.
-Yeah, I say yes, too.
-No, I never dated Gisele!
What -- Are you kidding me?!
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
I love that, though!
I love that I got you
on that, right?
Whew!
-When I was on "SNL," you know,
like, Colin Jost is married
to Scarlett Johansson.
-Yeah, you're right.
-You know what I mean?
Like, when I was on "SNL,"
you know, Drew Barrymore
didn't look at me.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Okay, I'm --
Dude, I made up that thing
about horses, too.
-I don't even know
who Gisele is.
-I'm assuming she likes --
-She's married to Tom Brady.
-Oh, for real?
-For real.
[ Laughter ]
-What she do?
-She's a supermodel.
-She just sound exotic.
-You don't know Gisele?
-No. She sound exotic, though.
-She's married to Tom Brady.
-Dude.
-And she's so famous,
she pays all the bills!
[ Laughter ]
-Alright --
-She's that one!
-Yes. She's the greatest.
What you got? You have 1 or 2.
What do you think? Number 1.
-Number 1?
-Yeah.
-Alright. Is it going to be easy
for us to get this?
-I mean, I've heard
some things about 21.
-Mm-hmm.
-Uh...
[ Laughter ]
-How many hours?
How many hours?
-A few. It say "a few."
-Yeah, a few. Nuh-unh.
I'm absolutely -- That's the
only question I needed to ask.
Case closed.
-In what state?
-California.
-Califo-- See, if he said
Florida, I'd go, "That's true."
-Yeah, that's my -- Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
They give them out a little --
Yeah.
Piloting what?
-Plane. Pilot.
What else --
-No --
-What else do you pilot?
-Could be a helicopter.
-I assume it's a plane.
-This is insane.
I already know this.
This is crazy.
He doesn't know how many hours,
doesn't know helicopter
or a plane.
-In L.A.
-When did you start?
-California.
-I know where L.A. is.
-A while back, a while back.
-Yeah.
Ballpark, ballpark.
-Probably two years.
-Why you want to fly so bad?
-I wanted to be in the Air Force
when I was young.
[ Laughter ]
-The rapping soldier?
-The rapping soldier? Yeah --
-I never heard
of a rapping soldier.
-Yeah. Really.
I believe that.
Flaps up or flaps down?
-Flaps down.
[ Laughter ]
-I made that up. I made that up.
Yeah, I didn't know
what that meant.
I figured
maybe that'd crack him.
Something -- Flaps up,
flaps down, I don't know.
-Did you -- So,
you don't have your license,
so you didn't fly yourself
here today, did you?
-Nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah.
-No, that would only
help your cause.
-Right, I would have it.
If I flew here, that would be
my last couple of hours.
-Where'd you come from?
-California.
-That's more than two hours.
-Five.
[ Laughter ]
Five.
-Hmm.
-That would have put me
over the threshold.
[ Laughter ]
-I believe that you do want
to get your pilot's license,
but I do not think that you are
a few hours away from it.
-What you say?
-I'm gonna say false.
-Now he's a little
too confident here.
Wait, hold on.
I'm going to say that's a lie.
-It's a lie?
-Yes.
-It's the truth.
-Oh!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow! Wait, wow --
So, really? So you're close
to getting your pilot's license?
-Yeah, but not, like,
to fly, like, big planes.
It's like single-engine planes,
like propeller planes.
-Really?
-Wow.
-That's fascinating!
-Yeah.
-Dude, that's great.
You totally got me on that one.
-Got me.
The first rapper to fly.
-That's what I'm talking about.
My thanks to Chris Rock,
21 Savage!
Great job, both of you.